you'll never guess what mike ashley lost
60 million quid last night and i called
up a few of the newspapers and i go look
at this story how much would you pay me
news of the world go 10 grand i arranged
to meet this reporter
and it was like dimly lit and i walked
in there and it was
absolutely how you'd imagine a news of
the world reporter
to look right i'm just saying
stereotypically i'm not saying it will
look the same but this is how i
imagine that person to look and you look
exactly like it shiny suit slip back
hair
the whole works story ran it was a
double paid spread which i've still got
i still got it in my house and they paid
me 10 grand and i used that money to
start the business up with so
i've i've interviewed there was over
1500
people uh four recruitment consulting
positions within dg right so there's
been a lot
all things that we always looked for was
hunger
and drive which you can probably bunch
up together
a willingness to learn and humility
and ambition i saw it as a way of that
but you can't speak to your competitors
for us it was always okay so we should
be talking to
our competitors to learn about the
market for there for us to be able to
learn off them and
see what mistakes that they made we were
able to
escalate our learning by reaching out to
those sort companies and it was
absolutely invaluable